bonjour c'est moi la star tu peux je
sais que ça peut surprendre
j'ai plutôt l'air d'un
or financier dingue
industriel allemand jérémy mon associé
trentaine d'années barbu pantalons
courts se désole tous les jours de mes
tenues qu'ils trouvent pas assez cool
donc aujourd'hui je me le jean les
tennis pour avoir l'air intégré le fait
est que c'est assez récent il y a un an
encore
gt gt directrice innovation au sein du
groupe la poste
alors pourquoi ce choix une start up
quand j'ai rencontré jérémie dans un
incubateur lui il était coach
moi j'étais en formation je me suis
présenté il m'a dit non mais directeur
innovation dans un grand groupe
ça sert à rien alors je dois dire que
c'était une entrée en matière j'ai pas
forcément apprécié parce que s'il ya
bien quelque chose sur lequel le
directeur innovation en vie dans une
entreprise d'avoir ces de l'impact c'est
de créer la nouveauté le changement
d'ailleurs sonné la définition de
l'innovation pour moi c'était même plus
qu'un rôle c'était une mission et j'ai
trouvé de grand enthousiasme
j'ai eu des grandes périodes de doute
j'ai changé ma façon de faire d'une
feinte de l'envi de créer des nouveaux
projets des concepts mon sujet a été de
plus en plus autour de l'organisation
autour de comment le faire et finalement
j'ai eu l'impression que le contexte
dans lequel j'évolue et était de moins
en moins positifs moins en moins
favorables et pas que pour mon
entreprise je pense pour beaucoup
d'entreprises dans des contextes
industrielle de service et je
comparerais le métier de directeur
d'innovation à celui de quelqu'un qui
est en train de faire un chantre
permaculture en pleine beauce en zone
d'agriculture intensive
quand je suis rentré il ya neuf ans à la
poste
j'étais porté en pl n'enthousiasme
j'allais bien sûr inventé les nouveaux
business qui allait sauver la poste la
disparition du courrier
je venais du conseil de la confiance et
donc j'ai commencé par le b à ba ce que
j'avais appris à faire le benchmark
donc je suis allé à la poste suisse pour
voir quel était le meilleur processus de
management de l'innovation donc la poste
suisse oui c'était très très cadré à
chaque étape avec un comité de direction
une gouvernance extraordinaire puis je
suis allé en allemagne là il avait mis
des moyens considérables dans une entité
à part pour inventer la poste de demain
et puis je suis allé au japon c'est
yamato une société de livraison de colis
extraordinaire il livre de tout du
fragile du lourd du grand est le
dirigeant qui me présente son
organisation me dire a nommé chez nous
il n'ya que les livreurs qui peuvent
innover c'est eux qui sont au contact du
client tous les jours d'ailleurs ils ont
leurs numéros de téléphone et ils
peuvent interagir en cas de problème
seuls eux savent ce dont ils ont besoin
fait yamato c'est le terrain qui
innovent
alors bon moi je dois dire que j'étais
au siège bien loin du terrain et des
facteurs donc j'ai pas forcément s'y est
tout de suite la branche sur laquelle
était assise mais par contre j'ai quand
même gardé cette insight
7 cette mission ma mission n'était pas
seulement d'inventer des nouveaux
produits et même peut-être de moins en
moins mais bien de nourrir le terrain
qui porte les innovations alors je les
fais de différentes façons d'abord pour
moi il s'agissait de stimuler j'ai
commencé par stimuler l'innovation faire
des prototypes avec des start up que
l'on présentait une fois par an aulas
postale c'est un moment pour montrer ce
qui était possible
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait
s'approprier c'est devenu un moment très
important aujourd'hui vraiment une de
fait de l'innovation pour l'ensemble des
postiers
mais c'est pas uniquement stimuler c'est
aussi donner les moyens de faire maman
domaine c'était le numérique
donc j'ai développé des plateformes
eric ça peut paraître très technologique
des plateformes d'ouverture de donner
des plateformes d'ouverture de service
des api mais pour moi c'est une façon de
donner à tout un chacun au sein de
l'entreprise les moyens d'agir et de
prototypes et des services avec ce type
de plateforme ça voulait dire de la
formation mais pas que pour des
informaticiens aussi pour des marketeurs
des communicants et c'est comme ça sur
une plateforme de données ou du compte
des six lot l'information tout ce qui
constituait qui est produit par le
terrain on le met à disposition où sont
mes mots ça va tout simplement de vous
sans mes boîtes aux lettres où sont mes
mes bureaux de poste qu'est ce qu'il y a
tout autour on a énormément
d'informations quel est l'impact quelles
sont les émissions de co2 de mes
véhicules et en l'occurrence par exemple
une personne de la communication avait
pu prototype est comme ça un service qui
permettait d'interagir avec la
collectivité territoriale pour dire quel
est l'impact l'a maintenant en temps
réel de mon émission co2 c'est donc pas
seulement aussi donner les moyens aux
terrains le nourrir avec tout ce qu'il a
il le constituent c'est aussi planter
des graines jardiner faire pousser des
plants qui deviennent grands ou qui
meurt beaucoup parfois sont piétinés ou
qui vont sur le jardin d'un côté c'est
comme en agriculture il ya parfois des
moments d'ingratitude
mais aussi des belles récoltes et je
fais ce parallèle avec la permaculture
diamant mode de d'agriculture ou sur un
même terrain on va faire pousser des
plantes des fleurs des légumes et parce
que c'est toute cette diversité
le terrain va ils vont passer des
nutriments et le terrain va être
particulièrement riche et on a fait la
preuve de d'une très grande productivité
des terrains permaculture de par la
diversité et c'est ça développer
l'innovation c'est permettre cette
diversité et même au delà d'un nombre de
projets sur un même projet c'est comme
ça qu'il est développé
je donnerai l'exemple d'un projet il y a
quelques années que j'avais monté qui
s'appelait la voiture postale d'abord
l'idée de ce projet était venu un soir à
marseille une belle soirée un événement
d'innovation le lift qui était organisée
par la fille où il y avait des gens très
inspirant et je rencontre robin chaise
qui est la fondatrice de zipcar une
première société d'autopartage aux états
unis qui est devenu vraiment la porte
parole de l'économie collaborative pour
elle tout ce qui est en excédent doit
être utilisée est déployé pour la
majorité mais qui met vos véhicules
postaux qu'est ce que vous en faites le
week-end vous devriez les louer avec
cette idée en fait on revient je
travaille avec coulis car une une jeune
start up à l'époque d'autopartage et on
va chercher des compétences en
l'occurrence on a trouvé les compétences
qui avaient déployé le véhicule
électrique au sein de la poste pour
s'appuyer sur eux pour nous aider nous
aider à trouver des centres de tri
directeur qui vraiment par pure
curiosité
c'était clairement pas dans leur
objectif ont envie d'essayer et
d'expérimenter voir ce que cela donne
avec toutes ses richesses et cette
diversité
on a fait une expérimentation qui est
devenue une plan puisqu'elle fait partie
maintenant l'autopartage fait partie des
services d'une nouvelle business unit de
mobilité et en même temps coli car lui
s'est vendu avec une très très belle
valorisation
chez psa car l'expérimentation nous
avions monté ensemble leur avait apporté
beaucoup de force
c'est ça la permaculture c'est se
nourrir les uns des autres de nos
différences et de notre de nous inspirer
aussi un mutuellement
certaines organisations en off est un
mode de fonctionnement en l'occurrence
gore technologies la société qui a
inventé le gore texte est une entreprise
kent en mode de fonctionnement termes
d'organisation très très innovant et
pour eux au coeur de leur mode de
fonctionnement
c'est le fait de nourrir les ans les
gens les uns les autres les
collaborateurs et de travailler autour
de l'entr'aide entre ses collaborateurs
pour pouvoir nourrir l'innovation ils
ont en fait entériner cela avec un avec
leur mode de incentive un collaborateur
70% de sa prime et sur comment est-ce
qu'il a atteint ses objectifs
20 % c'est dans quelle mesure il a il a
aidé les autres à atteindre leurs
objectifs et 10% sur comment est-ce
qu'il s'est développé en termes de
compétences pour l'avenir
ce mode de fonctionnement qui est
vraiment autour de l'enrichissement l
entraide dans l'entreprise n'est pas un
mode de fonctionnement quand on retrouve
dans beaucoup d'entreprises et même dans
la majorité qui va être concentrée sur
un organisation autour de la performance
financière
autour finalement d'une agriculture
intensive un rendement maximum sur ce
qui fait ou ce jusqu'à présent mon
succès est d'ailleurs ces entreprises en
un outil magique pour les aider c'est le
rp un logiciel de gestion intégré qui
permet d'aligner l'ensemble des
processus sur le pilotage financier
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez vécu
le déploiement d'un erp et dans un grand
groupe
ce que vous avez fait moi
personnellement à l'innovation ça m'a
fait l'effet d'un drone qui balance du
roundup sur un champ rien n'y échappe
pas la moindre petite herbe folle moi
j'avais un contrôleur de gestion qui
m'aidaient sûr beaucoup d'affaires qui
me permettait qui me permettait
justement de payer les startups ans en
avance après donc jean claude a été
mutualisé et j'ai dû faire les bons de
commande attendra workflow qui du coup
numérique est devenu infinie et les
startups ont fait preuve de beaucoup de
patience
alors effectivement aujourd'hui andy
rolala il ya plein de corporate à coeur
c'est la façon d'innover mais comment
faire autrement d'ailleurs le problème
est comment faire autrement
l'audio moi même j'étais dans un grand
groupe pour un industriel pour pouvoir
vendre une expérimentation
machaie il me dit mais charmant le
garçon il me dit bon alors quand vous
n'êtes pas dans les achats on va passer
par une société de portage salarial qui
va donc vous prendre 10% sur votre
facture
voilà le jeune garçon très charmant qui
devient 'corporate' à coeur et est
finalement une performance en tout cas
sur modèle innovation qui restent à
discuter
donc oui aujourd'hui ses modes de
fonctionnement
ces logiciels qui ont aligné l'ensemble
de l'organisation ont régi dit fier
l'organisation est asséché le terrain et
le rôle de directeur d'innovation va du
coup être de 2,2 développer d'essayer de
jardiner ce terrain de démultiplier la
permaculture et de permettre les
croisements de re permettre la diversité
mois en partant en quittant ce métier de
jardinier
du coup j'ai imaginé un service
d'irrigation une solution d'irrigation
en partant par les hommes les ans et les
hommes et les compétences qui peuvent
s'enrichir entre eux et permettre de
faire gagner à l'entreprise
l'agilité qu'elle a pu perdre avec qu'au
barca et dit on une plate forme donc qui
permet à chacun de préciser ses
compétences celle d'aujourd'hui d'hier
de demain et de stimuler par des robots
la coopération et l'entraidé
par exemple c'est un jeune embauché qui
peut solliciter quelqu'un d'expérimenté
qui a vécu le terrain et c'est lui qui
va le mieux lui passer la culture et
l'expérience ou quelqu'un qui faisait du
véhicule électrique à un moment donné
venir aider sur un projet qui n'a pas
grand chose à voir sinon une expérience
de déploiement en termes de mobilité
donc oui avoir une start up c'est des
angoisses beaucoup c'est clairement
beaucoup moins sécurisante d'être dans
un grand groupe avec jérémie on fait de
la permaculture quotidienne de toutes
nos différences on fait pousser notre
plan en espérant qu'il y ait de beaux
fruits qui se développe
et en même temps pour moi c'est là une
façon de faire finalement toujours ce
que j'ai considéré être ma mission c'est
d'apporter de nourrir le terrain en
donnant les moyens aux hommes qui le
constituent de pouvoir se développer et
de s'entraider pour changer l'entreprise
merci
[Applaudissements]